si l'un des smartphones que je vais
énormément aimer cette année j'ai déjà
beaucoup aimé l'année dernière et que je
vais beaucoup aimer cette année c'est le
zenfone 10 de Asus pourquoi et bien
parce qu'en fait il fait un truc que les
autres ne font quasiment plus c'est à
dire proposer un tout petit format tout
petit format il est extrêmement compact
et c'est vraiment le gros point fort de
ce smartphone parce que la plupart des
smartphones vont avoir des écrans de
plus en plus grands 6,5 6,7 pouces ça
devient énorme alors ce qui est génial
c'est qu'on a un vrai confort entre
parler du contenu vidéo et compagnie
mais il y a plein de personnes qui ne
veulent pas nécessairement d'un très
grand smartphone alors Asus du coup a
pris le pli surtout l'année dernière ça
a vraiment été affirmé dernière avec le
zenfone 9 et je vous l'ai déjà montré je
les mets déjà beaucoup avec un écran un
peu plus petit et là il continue dans
cette démarche avec le zenfone 10 alors
pour autant bien qu'ils aient un écran
petit ils n'ont absolument pas lâché la
performance il y a beaucoup de
performance donc aujourd'hui je vais
vous présenter ce smartphone que Asus ma
gentiment envoyé en avant-première
d'ailleurs gentiment envoyé un mais pas
qu'un plein j'ai quasiment toutes les
couleurs il manque juste le noir bon le
noir c'est noir vous saurez donc là
comme ça on peut bien se rendre compte
je vais donc vous présenter aujourd'hui
le zen fone 10 d'Asus vous allez voir
c'est un smartphone qui est super cool
parce que niché mais aussi super
intéressant allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous intéresser ici alors ce qui est
cool quand même c'est que et bien bien
que vous ayez un smartphone qui soit
avec un écran compact en termes de prise
en main il est très bon regardez là dans
la main c'est pas du tout déconnant ça
va ça se promet une fois de plus j'ai
pas des très grandes mains mais ça
déconne pas et ça va vraiment bien ça
c'est vraiment un très gros point fort
qu'on va venir aimer sur ce smartphone
c'est la compacité c'est également la
finesse il fait un petit
68,1 mm alors bon c'est pas très évident
de se rendre compte comme ça mais je le
trouve assez fin et ça c'est bien si
vous venez le mettre à côté d'un iPhone
14 pro max bien vous allez voir que en
termes de taille c'est quand même
relativement différent vous voyez il est
quand même vachement plus petit sur le
côté en termes de finesse il est
également aussi un peu plus petit enfin
un peu plus fin voilà ça se joue à pas
grand chose mais vraiment un poil plus
fin surtout il est plus léger avec ses
172 grammes en plus on fait un truc
assez mignon c'est qu'ils ont mis
différentes couleurs alors j'aime bien
je trouve assez sympa j'aime bien alors
le truc qui est déjà assez cool c'est
que on a un revêtement qui est un côté
un peu texturé un peu matière je sais
pas réellement ce que c'est il y a une
espèce de côté faux gomme entre une
espèce de fausse microfibre sans poil
sans fibres c'est assez bizarre je sais
et mais on sent vraiment la matière sur
le doigt alors le truc qui est cool
c'est qu'il y a pas de terrasse après ça
laisse quelques petites impuretés qu'on
peut venir normalement nettoyer mais bon
voilà rien de déconnant alors vous
l'avez soit en bleu comme ça soit il
existe en blanc si vous voulez un truc
neutre cet espèce de blanc glacé qui est
assez joli alors il y a aussi un noir de
base mais je l'ai pas j'ai aussi cette
couleur verte que je trouve très jolie
et puis il y a cette espèce de petit
rouge un peu cassé qui est aussi assez
élégant alors personnellement je vais
venir préférer le bleu je trouve un peu
plus un peu plus jolie je sais pas
pourquoi parce que une question de goût
le goût les couleurs derrière dites-moi
vous quel est votre couleur préférée en
bas l'autre truc qui est assez marrant
il y a ces distinctif et c'est de
grosses optique on va venir retrouver
sur le côté qui pour le coup sont
vraiment juste énormes ça fait une
espèce de gros yeux alors je trouve ça
marrant ces gros optiques ça vient de
typé mais tout de suite ce que je vois
et ce qui se trouve un peu dommage c'est
que pour voir qu'on est sur le flag type
d'Asus on n'a pas de téléobjectif c'est
un choix de la marque grand angle ultra
grand-angle vous allez voir que j'en
fasse super boulot au niveau de ce grand
angle mais il y a pas de télé donc sur
un smartphone haut de gamme c'est quand
même con de ne pas pouvoir avoir un tel
objectif pour venir zoomer dans l'image
au moins un X2 optique ça aurait été
bien c'est pas le cas ça sera uniquement
du numérique et bien qu'on a un capteur
de 50 mégapixels ça fait quand même un
petit peu râler de pas pouvoir avoir un
zoom optique ici oui ça pour plus
rapidement être un petit peu limité
alors que certains autres vont jusqu'à
un X 10 optique là bon il y en a pas il
y en a pas il y en a pas côté photo je
trouve ça assez efficace sur le grand
angle que ce soit la fontaine qu'on a
devant que ce soit les détails au niveau
des personnes les différentes zones
d'ombre le soleil c'est assez joli rien
un petit peu de bruit ici et par là mais
globalement le rendu est correct il
fonctionne bien alors l'ultra
grand-angle a pas été la même sauce hein
soyons clairs c'est pas le même capteur
ça va être un peu plus désaturé par
rapport au grand-angle alors on peut
venir zoomer numériquement x 2 on peut
et après on évite de se rapprocher trop
près parce que comme c'est du zoom
numérique c'est pas ouf mais dans
l'ensemble le taf est fait et sur ce
capteur grand-angle j'aime bien vous
allez voir je vous en montre
quelques-unes c'est plutôt plutôt assez
assez efficace là la cathédrale de
Clermont-Ferrand magnifique me
direz-vous venez nous voir vous allez
voir c'est joli l'ultra grand-angle pas
mal un peu plus déformant on le voit
notamment ici au niveau des jambes des
gens mais vu comme je l'ai fait ici
forcément c'est normal et ici rien de
déconnant mais globalement c'est pas mal
ce que zoom numérique x2 ça va pas mal
là c'est pareil je trouve ça assez joli
très efficace entre d'un côté la zone
dont on a là le ciel bon voilà c'est
plutôt pas mal à côté légèrement un poil
sur saturé au niveau logiciel mais un
poil le mode portrait aussi fonctionne
pas mal et des tours plutôt bien là
petit point de détail ici au lieu un peu
plus de mal mais dans l'ensemble le taff
est fait regardez là ça fonctionne quand
même plutôt pas trop mal la caméra de
selfie elle est quand même en dessous du
mal à être nette pas Gégé pas venir
recommandé par contre votre caméra
arrière elle est hyper efficace regardez
là il fait beau il fait chaud c'est
efficace c'est joli ultra grand-angle
une fois de plus c'est la différence au
niveau de la saturation mais sinon
globalement c'est pas trop mal alors là
il a eu un petit peu de mal là vous
voyez c'était un peu plus orangé je les
ai un petit peu moins alors c'est pas
parfait il manque encore quelques
petites choses peut-être que Asus
pourrait venir corriger d'un point de
vue algorithmique mais dans l'ensemble
le rendu est quand même relativement
correct par contre j'aime bien après
alors vous avez ce petit picto ici de
Asus qu'on retrouve sur le côté c'est à
dire que ça a vraiment le ça devient
vraiment le dessiner j'ai le nom du
smartphone Asus zenfone et j'ai les
petites flèches rouges tu te flèches
rouges à gauche petite flèche rouge à
droite pour vraiment venir indiquer la
photo et venir le signifier le marquer
fortement au niveau du smartphone comme
expliquant que c'est quelque chose qui
est fort et qui dans l'ADN de ce produit
donc voyez on a vraiment deux gros
points distinctifs et deux gros points
forts voyez à l'arrière c'est la photo à
l'avant cet écran avec également ce
capteur d'empreinte digitale qu'on a sur
la tranche qui déverrouille rapidement
qui est bien qui est pratique alors vous
allez voir il y a plein de de
fonctionnalités qui sont du maître Asus
et notamment une fonctionnalité qui est
vraiment géniale vraiment orienter ce
smartphone au niveau de la photo
et que vous êtes là et d'un coup tiens
il se passe quelque chose et vous voulez
faire une photo sauf que le temps
d'allumer votre smartphone d'aller dans
l'application Photos et de mettre en
face c'est passé donc cool génie d'Asus
là-dessus c'est de se dire ok on va
faire un truc on va appuyer deux fois
ici tac et là ça prend trois photos à la
suite et vous retrouver vos photos
directement là alors le truc est assez
malin parce qu'en fait ça vous chute
directement et vous avez pas assez deux
trois secondes que vous perdez vous
voyez tac tac vous appuyez ça shoot
alors la seule contrainte que vous avez
c'est soit d'avoir le smartphone à la
main soit de le sortir de la poche et de
faire attention tac tac hop là ça shoot
directement ça vous a pris les photos et
vous les retrouvez là vous voyez vous
êtes là vous êtes beau vous faites un
joli sourire bravo à vous donc ça c'est
extrêmement malin et je trouve ça bien
vu de la part d'Asus c'est comment
rajouter des petites fonctionnalités
pourront les choses un peu plus malide
et c'est là où aussi Asus c'est assez
fort c'est du point de vue de
l'expérience logiciel parce que ils ont
quand même pensé à pas mal de choses
alors après si ça vous intéresse je vous
laisserai aller fouiner dedans mais vous
avez pas mal de petites choses au niveau
de la gestion de l'énergie au niveau de
la gestion de la recharge qui est assez
malin on peut venir choisir comment on
va venir recharger on peut programmer sa
recharge voyez économie d'énergie
programmée on peut passer sur un mode
durable par exemple entre deux heures du
matin et 6h du matin pour éviter de
venir taper dans la batterie c'est bien
parce que la nuit globalement on
l'utilise pas donc tout ce qui va être
notification essayez ça on le bloque et
on s’emmerde pas entretient de la
batterie charge lente charge planifiée
bref ça c'est un truc qui est pas
nouveau qui était déjà avant chez Asus
mais je trouve très très cool
sélectionner une limite de charge voyez
moi je fais la tombée à 80 je veux pas
charger à 100 % je charge à 80 comme ça
j'ai vite devenir abîmer ma batterie et
d'aller trop loin recherche planifier je
peux dire je vais recharger par exemple
entre 4h du matin et 7h du matin si je
le branche sur le secteur il va pas
charger toute la nuit charge et puis
décharger quand il arrive un peu vers le
haut déchargé rechargé c'est pas très
très bon tu chargera uniquement dans le
laps de temps que je lui ai dit ça c'est
bien donc vous voyez il y a toutes ces
petites optimisations qui sont vraiment
très très Malines ici de la part d'Azur
entre détails mais pas pas uniquement un
détail vous allez dans l'affichage et
vous avez le taux de rafraîchissement
alors taux de rafraîchissement il est en
automatique vous voyez je vais avoir du
120 90 60 hertz et en fait il va monter
jusqu'à 144 Hertz mais uniquement
lorsque vous serez en train de jouer un
jeu donc ça c'est pareil c'est vraiment
dans l'ADN d'Asus le gaming vous voyez
je me lance un jeu je pars du haut de la
gauche et je vais tac comme ça et là
j'arrive dans le mode jeu d'Asus le Game
génie réel je vais pouvoir faire plein
de choses l'alto de rafraîchissement il
est en automatique 60 80 vous le verrez
pas bien s'écrit un tout petit 90 en 20
et là je passe en 144 Hz mais une fois
de plus il faudrait une loupe pour que
je vienne vraiment vous le montrer voyez
la chanson 44 automatique 609020 144
après là je suis en mode dynamique mais
je peux venir changer également la façon
dont je veux venir jouer sur un mode un
peu plus brutal un mode qui va
économiser un peu plus d'énergie donc
vous venez vraiment le mettre où vous
voulez comme vous voulez en fonction du
genre en fonction de ce que va vous
demander le jeu en fonction de la
batterie qui vous reste également tout
en sachant que et là vous êtes vraiment
pas limité vous êtes sur instant dragon
8 GN2 donc des processeurs le plus
rapide le plus performant du moment ciné
Qualcom qui va très très bien alors
au-delà de ce mode jeu c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui tartine un max et vous
avez aucun problème là-dessus donc là
vous le voyez on va jusqu'à 120R pour
tout ce qui va être affichage multimédia
mais après pour tout le reste et bien
vous montez effectivement 144 heures
pour le gaming on est sur un écran
AMOLED résolution Full HD plus il y a un
autre point sur lequel Asus travaille
vachement alors eux ils travaillent avec
d'Irak au niveau de l'audio ils vous ont
mis des haut-parleurs stéréo avec
haut-parleur ici un deuxième
haut-parleur qui va se situer là alors
après il y a plein de petites techno au
niveau de la spatialisation de l'audio
je pas mal au niveau de l'audio comme un
peu tous les smartphones comme vous
n'avez pas une symétrie parfaite au
niveau des haut-parleurs on va avoir un
son qui va être un peu plus médium sur
la gauche un peu plus rond au niveau de
la droite le truc par contre qui
vachement bien c'est qu'ils ont
smartphone qui malgré tout assez complet
bien que vous n'ayez pas de téléobjectif
c'est que vous avez ici une prise jack
3.5 donc si vous voulez venir brancher
un casque vous pouvez donc vous êtes en
IRL audio sans problème et vous êtes
également en irise audio wireless vous
avez du Bluetooth 5.3 ou globalement
techniquement il y a ce qu'il faut
derrière vous avez en plus alors
vraiment pensant que tu as un peu plus
technique il travaille avec Welcome au
niveau du Snapdragon Sand vous avez de
l'APTX adaptatif et vous avez également
de la PTX l'osless comme ça vous savez
tout comme c'est une bête de compète
alors je vais pas vous l'ouvrir pour
vous le montrer mais vous avez en terme
de techno tout ce qui va bien à
l'intérieur vous avez soit 8 soit 16 Go
de RAM carrément on va pas jusqu'à 12 on
va jusqu'à 16 on pousse plus loin c'est
de la lpdr 5x dernière technodrame qui
va très bien qui va très vite et vous
avez 68 soit 256 soit 52 Go de stockage
en effet 4.0 c'est également intéressant
avec cette technologie de RAM et cette
technologie de stockage c'est qu'elles
vont venir jouer au niveau de
l'autonomie l'autonomie de votre
smartphone c'est pas uniquement la
taille de votre batterie ici à titre
d'information vous avez une batterie
plus de 4300 millions Pereire
l’autonomie elle se joue bien évidemment
avec la taille de la batterie mais la
phase de jouer également au niveau du
processeur si vous avez un bon
processeur qui est pas très énergivore
et bien ça mènera le smartphone un peu
plus loin ici vous avez un dragon 8 GN2
donc très bon niveau de l'autonomie en
plus le fait d'avoir cette technologie
de RAM et de Rome vous permet de jouer
également au niveau de l'autonomie donc
vous avez un smartphone qui sur le
papier est super intéressant pour
l'autonomie vous allez le garder
facilement une bonne journée voire un
peu plus si affinité ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de vos usages ça c'est
plutôt cool et hot point qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que vous avez hop là
on vient tout ouvrir un bloc de charge à
l'intérieur vous avez de la recharge 30
watts inclus ici signé Asus donc ça
c'est plutôt tout petit très cool aussi
et de la recharge sans fil 15 watts ici
pas de recharge inverse ça c'est cool
maintenant il y a un autre point qui est
supra intéressant c'est tout ce qui nous
ont fait au niveau de la photo alors
regardez je vous montre ici je vous fais
un petit truc tout mignon pour vous
montrer vous avez donc deux capteurs
vous avez un grand angle de 50
mégapixels ça c'est très cool pour venir
shooter en rond pour avoir du détail si
vous souhaitez bon ok on connaît au
niveau des smartphones il y a pas
grandes nouveautés et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils ont mis une
techno qu'on trouve notamment chez vivo
c'est une caméra sur stabilisation
optique donc qui va stabiliser sur 6
axes qui vous permet d'avoir un truc qui
est hyper smooth et hyper fluide que
vous avez alors on s'en fout un peu on
est au Parc Monceau ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir en fait le
petit rond que vous avez au milieu et le
petit rond il est intéressant pour quoi
parce qu'en fait votre billet doit
rester au centre est tant que votre
billet reste au centre vous êtes hyper
stabilisé et vous allez avoir un
résultat hyper stabilisé si maintenant
vous commencez à bouger un peu trop et
que votre vie vous voyez elle commence à
sortir c'est là où la stabilisation elle
se perd et c'est là où ça marche moins
bien alors il y a les filles gimball
bien évidemment avec la stabilisation
sur 6 axes et puis il y a aussi
l'électronique derrière la stade
électronique qui vient vraiment
compenser ça et qui apporte un effet
hyper smooth et je trouve ça juste
bluffant donc là je suis en train de
filmer en 4K 30 sur le grand angle si je
change je passe sur l'ultra grand-angle
vous voyez j'ai plus l'habille parce que
je suis plus sur le Game ball donc là je
le perds je repasse en 1 je récupère à
ma petite big gimball et je laisse
appuyer et je peux venir monter x 2
normalement vous voyez j'ai encore
m'habille gimbo le qui est juste là et
qui me permet d'avoir à cette
stabilisation ça c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal donc là je lance enregistrement
voyez on part on se balade alors
attention il y a les poubelles par ici
on a la bille qui est au centre alors
vous le voyez pas mais moi je le vois
parce que je suis en train d'enregistrer
et ça ne bouge absolument pas donc là je
fais attention parce que je redescends
là et vous allez avoir un résultat qui
est hyper smooth hyper fluide alors je
vais pas les courir je vais pas aller
faire fou avec mais voyons on peut se
déplacer tant que la bille reste au
centre et je vois qu'elle reste dedans
il y a la stabilisation ça bouge pas
c'est pratique ça c'est hyper hyper cool
et je trouve ça juste hallucinant alors
c'est vachement bien parce qu'en fait ce
smartphone se permet de le dédie a pas
mal de personnes on passe à tous les
créateurs qui veulent pas s'embêter qui
veulent une super stabilisation ou des
gens qui comme moi ou en tremblement
essentiel et pour le coup là ça va pas
bouger donc je trouve ça juste hyper
hypra hypra efficace de pouvoir l'avoir
comme ça donc je pense que vous en
pensez dites le bon dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous trouvez ça
efficace oui non après je vais switcher
la sur l'ultra grand-angle donc là ça va
venir ça qu'elle est davantage on va
plus sentir les mouvements parce que
regardez là je monte je descends parce
que forcément bah je suis pas sur la
même sur cette game Ball et je repasse
en un et là je vais pouvoir remonter
redescendre un peu vous voyez je bouge
voilà je bouge un petit peu normalement
ça n'a pas bougé donc ça c'est quand
même vachement cool ça c'est intéressant
pour deux choses la première chose c'est
pour la photo ça vous permet d'avoir des
photos qui ne bougeront pas quelle que
soit les photos que vous allez faire sur
votre grand-angle pas sur l'ultra
grand-angle bien évidemment ici donc ça
c'est grâce à la stabilisation optique
deuxième point qui est intéressant c'est
sur la vidéo bien évidemment ça va être
smooth ça va être beaucoup plus simple
vous fera des vidéos qui seront beaucoup
plus stabilisés ça c'est très très cool
maintenant ils ont l'air encore un peu
plus loin ça c'est le matériel c'est au
niveau de la stabilisation logiciel
parce qu'on fait ce qu'ils sont venus
faire c'est de se dire ok la
stabilisation optique c'est bien mais on
voit les plus loin au niveau de la
stabilisation électronique alors ce qui
se passe au niveau de la stabilisation
électronique et qu'en fait vous avez
votre image qui est comme ça et lui il
vient cadrer à l'intérieur venir
stabiliser électroniquement donc en fait
c'est bien ces logiciel mais ça mange un
petit peu d'image fait eux ils ont fait
un truc c'est de la stabilisation
électronique adaptative d'adaptative eis
en fait il va venir s'adapter en
fonction des mouvements de votre
smartphone c'est à dire qu'il va venir
stabiliser optiquement mais stabiliser
électroniquement pendant une vue
logiciel et si votre smartphone bouge
beaucoup effectivement il va venir
crouper davantage pour venir compenser
mais si votre smartphone ne bouge pas
beaucoup ou très très peu et bien il va
venir s'adapter en croûte un petit peu
moins et on vous laissant davantage
d'informations dans l'image donc l'idée
ça trouve plutôt pas mal et au niveau de
la photo alors le logiciel sera assez
basique photo vidéo intervalle de temps
ok du timelap le ralenti portrait le
panorama le sillon lumineux ça vous
pouvez venir le faire grâce à cette
stabilisation sur 6 axes et après vous
pouvez venir ajouter vous avez également
un menu le mode pro vidéo en mode manuel
si vous le souhaitez et comme il est là
il est déjà pas mal si vous allez dans
la photo vous allez dans vos paramètres
il faut venir comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure appuie sur deux fois sur
un bouton de volume pour que ça fait
faire trois photos lorsque l'écran est
éteint et bien il faut que vous veniez
ici et il faut que vous alliez dans
raccourci pour l'extinction de l'écran
vous cliquez là ça vous explique comment
ça marche vous l'activez alors vous
choisissez soit c'est un coup de chaud
ça vous prend trois photos soit ça vient
l'ancien enregistrement de la vidéo soit
ouvrir la caméra soit ouvrir la caméra
de selfie on vous le paramétrez comme
vous voulez je trouve ça très mal il est
prêt en plus pour le wi-fi 7 vous avez
comme je vous dis du Bluetooth 5.3 du
NFC c'est bien évidemment un smartphone
5G sans aucun problème et que je trouve
extrêmement cool pourquoi parce que si
vous voulez un smartphone très
performant endurant de bonne qualité
avec un petit écran si vous voulez un
format compact vous voulez quand même de
la qualité que vous voulez que ça aille
bien que ça tartine et que ça marche
vraiment bien sur la dernière version
d'Android et bien ici avec le zenfone 10
vous avez vraiment de quoi faire moi
c'est un smartphone qui me plaît qui me
plaît beaucoup je les mets déjà le
zenfone 9 j'aimais bien ce qu'ils font
juste globalement au niveau des
smartphones c'est vrai que c'est une
marque qui est assez méconnue en fait il
y a pas beaucoup de personnes qui
connaissent vraiment les smartphones
d'Asie pour autant c'est dommage parce
que c'est vraiment des produits qui sont
de très bonne qualité le logiciel est
toujours super bien pensé et super malin
et puis une fois de plus cette niche
avec ce format compact je trouve ça
vraiment génial donc je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous plaît est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu un smartphone d'Asus
est-ce que vous aviez eu le zenfone 9
alors si pour le coup vous êtes déjà le
zenfone 9 gardez-le même si c'est la
version de l'année dernière ça sert à
rien de changer trop régulièrement mais
si vous avez soit un vieux smartphone
soit vous êtes sur iOS et vous voulez
revenir sur Android et que vous voulez
surtout un format compact que vous
voulez la compacité que vous voulez un
écran un peu plus compact même si quand
même on va pas se mentir 5,9 pouces
c'est assez grand et bien le zenfone 10
est juste top ici donc dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires
personnellement je l'adore je trouve
très très bien j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
à venir l'utiliser donc je pense que
pour me dire ce que vous en pensez puis
si vous intéresse une fois de plus je
vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description voilà je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous très bientôt et
bisous et beaucoup d'amour Ciao